i once thought pete davidson was just
like obama biracial goofball who ruined
a once beloved institution but it turns
out i was wrong
pete's not biracial
good one and now for the man of the hour
[Music]
this guy is a monster and uh he should
go to jail forever but
if you support the catholic church isn't
that like the same thing as being an r
kelly fan
like no
i don't really see the difference
only like one's music is significantly
better
you might know ludicrous from your mom's
that's what i call music cd
[Applause]
nothing can happen this was my first and
last tonight show
now it's fine i'll go on set
you've been going i actually have seth's
number i don't have your number so i'm
sad uh what kanye said after he went off
the air last week was one of the worst
like most awkward things i've ever seen
here and i've seen chevy chase speak to
an intern
i'm like on the left i'm like oh god
and then i'm like i want a career so i
leave
yeah cuomo uh he looks like a guy that's
sleeping with your mom but stays
overnight and eats breakfast with you in
his boxers
and then and then he asked you how the
baseball's going and you say you don't
play baseball and he goes oh queer
snoop sun just got accepted to play
division one college football yeah
so snoop dogg found out he has a son
then kanye said that democrats broke up
black families with welfare and that's
slavery is not real
um do you know how wrong about politics
you have to be for like me to notice
jimmy carr is here when i first met
jimmy carr i thought wow jeff dunham's
puppets are getting amazing
jimmy you look like a butler in a
haunted mansion
all right so is there anything kanye can
do to win you back yeah um there is and
i'll tell you in a way that kanye
understands i made this uh make kanye
2006 again
i'm not insane i know i shouldn't be
making fun of how anyone looks
uh
i look like i make vape juice in a
bathtub
i look like a dr seuss character went to
prison
you auditioned for donald trump everyone
in the cast auditions yeah let me just
before you they made us all audition i i
wasn't at home like let's go yeah i was
so upset that i had to do it it was just
very it was very by the way he's upset
that he has to be president so that
might have you could have pulled from
that
dork
all right i'm sorry that's all right
it's we were on very late um johnson you
know i lost my dad on 9 11 and i always
regretted growing up without a dad until
i met your dad justin
now i'm glad mine's dead
um i don't like people with uh robotic
legs
i'm not done
uh
i don't like people with robotic legs
that like wear shorts
you know
because i you know i feel like if you
put on a pair of pants nobody would know
you know i feel like you're wearing
shorts so everybody knows
you know so you could cut the line at
coldstone and get your ice cream in
front of everybody else because that's
what happened to me
tell you this much
i was next in line at colestone all of a
sudden [ __ ] robocop walked in and all
of a sudden he was in front of me
and i was like i don't think this would
have happened if you had pants on
can joe budden shut the [ __ ] up by the
way
like stop
like who are you stop talking
you have one song that was in mean girls
go [ __ ] yourself okay
you [ __ ]
old tool bag
what is he gonna do write a dis about me
that's how much of a loser he is he's
like yes
i get this this comedian
[ __ ] tool bag
[Music]
i wasn't gonna do jokes about this but
then my buddy told me he's like yo i've
recently heard that uh ariana said she
had no idea who you were and she just
dated you as a distraction
so now i just think it's like fair game
uh so yeah also don't applause this
isn't like a drake first lil wayne
concert like this isn't like a
competition you know she has you know
her songs and stuff and this is what i
have okay so
all right that's that's it right
um so and you're like pete this isn't
fair you're like you're airing out dirty
laundry how could you do that where did
she say this stuff to her friends in the
confidence of her own home
no she said it on the cover of vogue
magazine
can you imagine if i did that cue
imagine if i did that
my career will be over tomorrow if i
spray painted myself brown and hopped on
the cover of vogue magazine
and just started [ __ ] on my ex can
you imagine the no don't clap that was a
draper's little wing claps i don't like
that i like the giggles
it's just jokes
but you imagine if i did that [ __ ] about
i was like yeah i just [ __ ] cause i
was bored and then fortnight came out
it'd be insane
and you're like well pete something had
happened to her right you know there had
to be some repercussions right no she
won billboard's woman of the year
and i got called butthole eyes by
barstoolsports.com
so sometimes life is a little unfair
again these are jokes i don't want any
smoke okay from my biggest fear is i'm
gonna get a shot in the back of that by
like a nine-year-old with a ponytail
and the last thing i'm gonna hear is
hashtag cancelled and then just pop
right in the back of that
and i don't want no smoke from the
from the nine-year-olds um
no she's a really powerful woman that uh
that that uh ariana she's a she's a very
very powerful woman you know
and very smart you know you gotta be to
be able to ruin starbucks for a person
you know i walked into starbucks the
other day i was like hey man i have a
medium coffee and the guy was like
i was like [ __ ] you i'm going to dunk it
down
why are they getting rid of them in the
city i can't find one
people a lot of people ask me all the
time uh you know like what what was that
what was it it's like any other breakup
you know it's just except everybody sees
it uh
yeah it's just it's uh like i i didn't
know what i was getting i kind of knew
what i was getting into but not really i
didn't know about the picture thing if i
knew about that i would have seen a
dermatologist before i started dating i
would have liked taking proper
precaution but
i didn't really you know it's like any
other breakup you have your boys over
they all lie to you you know they're
like dude no problem bro
nobody even knows who she is
oh it's all good bro it's all good
better off no problem you know and then
that song came out and my friends were
like bro i love you i love you right
[ __ ] is catchy
[ __ ] is very catchy you're gonna have a
rough eight months i'm sorry i'm sorry i
actually happen to like the song i'm
sorry
i like you
my grandfather said he goes
it's a slap
peter peter it's a slap uh i'm really
sorry uh
it's a good song and i don't i don't
even listen to that [ __ ] i was like i
get it
[Laughter]
um but yeah uh this is the only thing i
didn't like that i got out of it
whichever is a common misconception uh i
don't like that she talked all this [ __ ]
on like behalf of my dick i thought that
was like super weird
she was like yeah it didn't work out but
like nice dick
i thought that was really weird because
like everybody was like oh that that's
what a nice what a nice uh girl
first of all let's take a step back can
you imagine if i said that [ __ ]
you imagine i was like sorry i didn't
work out nice [ __ ] no
that [ __ ] wet
good [ __ ] but sorry
it's ridiculous
yeah this is the only thing it just did
i didn't like it because uh it's just
simply not true uh yeah yeah it's just
not she has little tiny little hands she
has
just very little hands everything's
[ __ ] huge to her
yeah it was a [ __ ] joke the entire
time we were down i was like you know
huge to you but small to everyone else
this rocks
you know
[Music]
so you ask yourself you're like why then
why if she knows this information then
why would she tell everybody what a
great big penis you have right why would
she do that you know because to the
outside you're like wow what a nice lady
didn't work out gave him a gave him a
nice word you know
told everybody has a nice penis right
that's not why
she did that so that she's a genius
remember this she's a very smart person
okay she did that so that every girl
that sees my dick for the rest of my
life is disappointed